T
IDEA IN THE WORLD.
WE WILL GET TO THAT IN A SECOND.
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS RIGHT THEN,
RIGHT TODAY IN THE WORLD -- NOW
TEXAS SENATOR TED CRUZ.
YOU KNOW, SENATOR I DON'T THINK
WE HAVE TO PUT BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
I THINK THE WAY DONALD TRUMP
BEAT THE CALIPHATE THAT GREW
UNDER OBAMA AND BIDEN WITH
PINPOINT ACCURACY AND MODERN
WEAPONRY AND TECHNOLOGY, OUR
MILITARY WAS PRESSING BUTTONS IN
AN AIR-CONDITIONED ROOM IN
TAMPA, FLORIDA.
WE DON'T NEED THAT OPTION.
YOU ARE A HISTORIAN OF
RONALD REAGAN.
RONALD REAGAN HELP THE FREEDOM
FIGHTERS, THE CONTRAS IN
NICARAGUA WITH WEAPONS.
HE HOPED BEAT THE SOVIET UNION
AND SOVIET UNIT LISTING OR
MISSILES.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT WE
WOULD DO THE SAME THING HERE AND
OUTPUT A SINGLE AMERICAN BOOTS
ON THE GROUND THROUGHOUT THIS
CONFLICT EVER.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> SEAN MIGHT THINK YOU'RE
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THAT WE CAN AND SHOULD HELP
UKRAINE WIN THIS WAR AND DEFEAT
RUSSIA AND DEFEAT PUTIN, BUT WE
SHOULD NOT PUT AMERICAN
SERVICEMEN AND WOMEN IN HARM'S
WAY.
WE SHOULD NOT PUT BOOTS ON THE
GROUND.
IT IS THE REASON I OPPOSE A NO
FLY ZONE.
TOMORROW MORNING, WE WILL HAVE
PRESIDENT ZELENSKYY WITH JOINT
SESSION OF CONGRESS REMOTELY.
I THINK HE MAY WELL ASK FOR A
NO-FLY ZONE.
I UNDERSTAND WHY HE WANTS THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN SOME DEMOCRATS,
SOME REPUBLICANS WHO HAVE
FOOLISHLY ECHOED THAT CALL.
A NO-FLY ZONE WOULD BE A MISTAKE
BECAUSE AMERICAN PILOTS AND
AMERICAN PILOT JETS IN CONFLICT
WITH RUSSIAN FIGHTER JETS.
THAT IS AN INVITATION TO
ESCALATION, AN INVITATION TO
WORLD WAR III.
WE DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT.
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT THERE
IS NOTHING WE CAN DO.
WE CAN DO A GREAT DEAL.
WE CAN PROVIDE LETHAL MILITARY
AID, AS YOU SAID STINGERS,
CHAPLAINS.
TWICE LAST YEAR JOE BIDEN HALTED
MILITARY AID TO UKRAINE,
DECEMBER AND APRIL OF LAST YEAR.
HE HALTED MILITARY AID TO
PRESSURE ZELINSKI TO GIVE INTO
RUSSIA.
CRITICALLY, WE SHOULD BE
PROVIDING JETS, JOE BIDEN WITH
THE POLISH MIGS TO GO TO KYIV.
THAT IS WHAT ZELINSKI SAID.
WE DID A CONFERENCE CALL AND
ZELINSKI SAID THE NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY WAS TO GET THOSE MIGS
THOSE JETS SO UKRAINIAN PILOTS
COULD DEFEND THEMSELVES FROM
RUSSIAN PILOTS.
YOU PLAY THAT RATHER PITIFUL
VIDEO OF NANCY PELOSI THAT SAID
GOSH, WE SHOULD GET THOSE MIGS.
NANCY EMMA THERE IS AN EASY WAY
TO DO IT, PICK UP THE PHONE AND
CALLED JOE.
JOE WAS THE ONE STOPPING IT.
JOE BIDEN IS THE ONE STOPPING
THE MIGS AND THAT DEVASTATION WE
ARE SEEING IN UKRAINE IS THE
DIRECT RESULT OF JOE BIDEN'S
WEAKNESS, APPEASEMENT, SURRENDER
TO PUTIN ON NORD STREAM 2.
TRAGICALLY AMONG THE CASUALTIES
THAT WE ARE SEEING ARE THOSE
HEROIC FOX REPORTERS AND MY DEEP
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILIES OF
PIERRE AND SASHA AND THE PRAYERS
WITH BENJAMIN APPEAR THEY ARE
HEROICALLY BEING ON THE GROUND
REPORTING WHAT IS HAPPENING AND
TRAGICALLY THEY PAID THE
ULTIMATE PRICE.
>> Sean: AND YOU KNOW, THEY
DID.
WHAT IS THE RATIONALE?
I UNDERSTAND YOUR ARGUMENTS
COMPLETELY AS IT RELATES TO THE
NO-FLY ZONE.
BUT I DON'T UNDERSTAND THE
RESISTANCE TO ARMING -- WHAT
DIFFERENCE DOES IT MAKE --
THEY'VE HAD SUCH SUCCESS WITH
JAVELINS AND THE STINGERS.
SO WHY THIS MYSTERIOUS
RELUCTANCE TOWARDS THE MIGS OR
ANY OTHER FIGHTER JETS?
IS JOE AFRAID VLADIMIR WILL GET
MAD AT THEM LIKE HE'S AFRAID
REPORTERS WILL GET MAD AND THE
STAFF WILL GET MAD AT HIM IF HE
ANSWERS REPORTERS QUESTIONS?
>> WELL, UNFORTUNATELY JOE BIDEN
AND KAMALA HARRIS AND HIS
ADMINISTRATION, THEY BELIEVE THE
WAY TO DEAL WITH BAD GUYS AND
THE WAY TO DEAL WITH ENEMIES IS
THROUGH GIVING IN AND
SURRENDERING, THROUGH WEAKNESS
AND APPEASEMENT.
WE HAVE SEEN THIS WITH RUSSIA,
CHINA, IRAN AND WITH VENEZUELA.
THAT IS THEY WERE AMMO.
IT HAS BEEN JOE BIDEN'S AMMO FOR
50 YEARS IS HE'S BEEN WRONG ON
EVERY FOREIGN POLICY QUESTION
FOR FIVE DECADES, LITERALLY
SINCE I WAS A TODDLER AND
JOE BIDEN ARRIVED IN THE SENATE.
HE HAS BEEN CONSISTENTLY WRONG.
SO YOU LOOK AT RIGHT NOW,
ZELENSKYY IS SAYING, WE NEED
FIGHTER JETS.
I HAVE TO TELL YOU THE SENATE
FOREIGN RELATIONS COMMITTEE,
THERE IS OVERWHELMING BIPARTISAN
CONSENSUS THAT WE SHOULD PROVIDE
THOSE FIGHTER JETS HERE THAT WE
HAD A RECENT BRIEFING WHERE
EVERY DEMOCRAT IN THE ROOM AND
EVERY REPUBLICAN IN THE ROOM
SAID "PROVIDE THE JETS NOW."
ABOUT BIDEN YOU IS GETTING
STINGERS AND CHAPLAINS AND OKAY
STINGERS AND JAVELINS ARE RIGHT
NOW SHOOTING DOWN RUSSIAN PLANES
AND KILLING RUSSIANS DO MICHAEL
RUSSIAN SOLDIERS BUT PASSING ON
THE RUSSIAN MAKES WOULD DO THE
SAME THING AND SHOOT DOWN
RUSSIAN PLANES IS UNNECESSARY
ESCALATION.
IT IS JUST BIDEN IS AFRAID OF
PUTIN.
AND NOT ONLY SHOULD WE BE
PASSING ON THOSE MIGS SO THE
UKRAINIAN PILOTS COULD USE THEM
BUT WE ALSO OUGHT TO BE
ENCOURAGING SOVIET BLOC NATIONS
AROUND UKRAINE TO MOVE AIR
DEFENSE SYSTEMS INTO UKRAINE'S
BORDERS TO BE ABLE TO DEFEND
THEMSELVES FROM RUSSIAN JETS.
LET ME BE CLEAR, TO GET THOSE
POLISH MIGS TO UKRAINE, WE
SHOULD NOT HAVE AMERICAN PILOTS
FLY THEM.
BUT RATHER WE SHOULD DO THE SAME
THING THE SAME PLAN IN POLAND TO
HAVE THE UKRAINIAN PILOTS GET
THEM COME UP AND IF THEY ENGAGE
WITH RUSSIA THEY ARE IN THE
MIDDLE OF AN ACT OF WAR.
THAT IS HOW WE DEFEAT THEM BUT
NOT ONLY THAT, WE COMBINED THEM.
WHAT BORIS JOHNSON SAID IN THE
CLIP THAT YOU PLAYED, WHICH IS
REALLY IMPORTANT, COMBINED WITH
UNDERCUT PUTIN 'REVENUE STREAM
BY TAKING AWAY OIL AND GAS
CUSTOMERS.
WE DO THAT BY UNLEASHING
AMERICAN PRODUCTION, ALLOWING
THE SOUP POWER, THE ENERGY
SUPERPOWER THAT IS AMERICA TO
PRODUCE OIL, GAS AND HE HAS
SIX PENDING APPLICATIONS TO
EXPORT LIQUID NATURAL GAS.
HE TO PROVE MIKE APPROVE EVERY
ONE OF THOSE TO TAKE AWAY
PUTIN'S CUSTOMERS.
NOTHING WILL UNDERCUT HIS
STRENGTH OR IN THE OLD KGB THUGS
AND OLIGARCHS TO RISE UP AGAINST
HIM MORE AND NOTHING WILL MORE
WE CAN SPEED 'ABILITY TO WAGE
WAR IN UKRAINE THEN TAKING AWAY
HIS REVENUE BY STEPPING IN AND
FULFILLING EUROPE'S ENERGY
NEEDS.
>> Sean: YOU KNOW
SENATOR CRIMEA WAS ANNEXED WHEN
JOE BIDEN WAS VICE PRESIDENT AND
OBAMA WAS PRESIDENT.
THE CALIPHATE GREW OUT
COMPLETELY WHILE JOE WAS
VICE PRESIDENT AND OBAMA WAS
PRESIDENT.
NOTHING HAPPENED WHEN
DONALD TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT.
AND HERE WE GO AGAIN NOW IT
SEEMS PUTIN HAS TAKEN OVER THE
WHOLE COUNTRY.
I'M NOT EVEN CONVINCED,
SENATOR AND THIS IS NOT A JOKE,
I AM NOT CONVINCED JOE BIDEN
KNOWS THAT TODAY IS TUESDAY.
AND THEN I JUST PLAYED THE TAPE
OF THE PRESIDENCY WHICH WOULD BE
THE SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE,
NANCY PELOSI.
AND LET'S JUST POINT OUT THAT
SHE SEEMS TO BE STRUGGLING ALSO
APPEAR THE WORLD IS WATCHING OUR
THREE TOP LEADERS, SENATOR.
AND I THINK THEY SEE NOTHING BUT
VULNERABILITY AND WEAKNESS.
THE GUY WITH THE MAIN TWEETS
BACK.
WE GOT TO HAVE STRENGTH.
>> SEAN, WHAT YOU'RE SAYING IS
TRAGICALLY TRUE AND WHAT IS
PARTICULARLY GALLING, THESE GUYS
SPENT FOUR YEARS DURING THE
TRUMP PRESIDENCY SAYING "THESE
GUYS DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY ARE
DOING" AND THE ADULTS ARE BACK
IN CHARGE.
THAT IS WHAT THEY CLAIM.
TODAY I WAS MEETING IN MY OFFICE
WITH A BIDEN NOMINEE TO BE
AMBASSADOR AND THAT NOMINEE
SAID, I ASKED HER, WHAT YOU
THINK OF THE BIDEN FORM POLICY
THIS YEAR?
SHE SAID IS WORKING GREAT, I
SAID CAN YOU GIVE ME ONE
EXAMPLE?
UKRAINE WE HAVE ENORMOUS
INTERNATIONAL CONSENSUS.
YOU HAVE TO BE FREAKING KIDDING
ME.
SINCE WORLD WAR II, YOU POINT TO
UKRAINE AS AN EXAMPLE OF THESE
GUYS SUCCESS?
MY GOD!
THIS WAS A DISASTER THEY CAUSED.
UKRAINE BECAUSE OF PUTIN'S
WEAKNESS AND WITHDRAWAL FROM
AFGHANISTAN, BECAUSE OF HIS
SANCTIONS ON NORD STREAM 2.
EVERY SINGLE ENEMY OF AMERICA IS
STRONGER, IS AN BOLDED PIER THE
CHANCES OF THE NEXT SHOE
DROPPING IN CHINA INVADING
TAIWAN ARE GROWING BY THE DAY
BECAUSE THEY SEE BIDEN'S
WEAKNESS.
AND BIDEN'S ADVERSARIES IN
VENEZUELA BEGGING MADURO TO SELL
OIL AND VIENNA WITH IRAN TO SELL
US OIL.
THEY WANT EVERY ENEMY TO GET
RICH AND USE BILLIONS TO KILL
AMERICANS.
THE ONE PEOPLE THEY DON'T WANT
TO ACTUALLY SELL OIL AND GAS ARE
AMERICANS THAT PRODUCE AMERICAN
JOBS.
IT IS LITERALLY, IF YOU SET DOWN
AND EVERY ENEMY OF AMERICA LET'S
HELP THEM AND BENEFIT THEM.
EVERY FRIEND OF AMERICA LET'S
ELIMINATE THEM, UNDERCUT THEM,
HURT THEM, SEAN YOU WOULD NOT
DEVISE A DIFFERENT FORM POLICY
THAN THE ONE BIDEN AND COMELLA
PUT IN PLACE.
>> Sean: THIS IS NOT A COUNTRY
THAT I RECOGNIZE RIGHT NOW.
IT IS NOT THE UNITED STATES THAT